hello there I'm gab welcome to the slow
mo guys in order to celebrate the
release of Gemini man upcoming movie we
have some lovely mannequins here of
young war Smith present-day
Will Smith and Will Smith and all Will
Smith oh oh will real life was the flesh
the flesh Prince how do you feel about
how do you feel about super slow-mo I
love super slow-mo I mean I've seen you
in slow-mo many movies yeah yeah yeah
you look a lot better in slimmer than I
do
Iran is slow-mo that was like that was
one of the shots that died through the
air yeah yeah yeah I was a good one
classic yeah that one that was good
I assume that the technology used in
Gemini man to make you appear younger
was slightly more advanced than a
mannequin but what you have going here
is it's not bad it's cutting edge it's
cutting edge like analog take a look at
the weaponry yes all right
ooh we are potatoes yeah we got we got a
spud gun we can use that later blood gun
in terms of it we'll start with a melon
amount like before we get to the
mannequin wanna practice and practice
the softer stuff like like a melon and
just like a bat one lead
a bat and a melon all right so your so
you'll pitch a melon well you probably
shouldn't pitch it because they're
hitting it no no I'm just thinking bet
I'd be hitting it finds a pitch they'll
be good on a stick okay maybe like the
sideways okay I might get a little bit
caked okay so where's the frame where's
the frame all right so we're good here
right let me frame up on you here that's
all it's all golf there's no I haven't
played baseball in so long it's all like
I love to slow mo guys
I like I've been I've been wanting to be
like a part of your team for a long time
I don't know I'm very excited to be here
I'm glad that happened today I saw the
video you made on your channel with all
the balloons yeah I was trying to steal
your stuff so do you have any any
pent-up aggression that you're gonna be
putting into this melon yeah I'm trying
to think about you know I'm trying to
think of my motivation you know I just
turned 51 last week right so I'm mainly
thinking about not hurting myself like
whatever you do yeah
don't tear a neck muscle on the slow mo
guys cuz you're gonna tear it in slow
motion oh the pole was much higher now I
knew not to hold on too tight
you see it come back in my face - it's
very sweet it's a very sweet melon in
the chops see the flinch move onto a
blade yes yeah
on that line huh
don't say that one should look good cuz
it's like I peel this whole cat is this
stuff I love to see like that
busting out is love good I feel this cap
will you had your laser focused eyes
never left the melon yeah checked his
wig off just wig off and then you got a
light coming through
did you taste that melon no no that
wasn't that one went away
that's very cool yeah there was almost
no shrapnel debris oh just like an ice
and then it just slopped off yeah like
that how do you feel about turning up
the heat
yes yeah turning up the heat he just
looked to me and he said yes yes in my
face yeah you just do it to the camera
yes yes you know that's what I learned
that a long time ago just say yes and
worry about it later
you dirty young me trying to kill Oh me
that's probably not a good line is that
it because the important thing is the
line that you say when you do it so
what's like I you dirty
you dirty young me trying to kill hold
me leave old me alone leave old man
leave old me alone you young me
have you ever fired a flame forever this
is my first time ever yeah this should
look really good
yes again pay attention the face yes be
glorious oh the line probably doesn't
matter because it's gonna be in slow
motion or weld a lot you'll use the line
before and then go into slow motion
yeah or I'll just I'll slow it down a
ton go down yeah yeah okay ready when
you are
all right dar you dirty young me Johnny
killed me
[Music]
okay fire extinguisher okay while we're
in there they shouldn't it be good to
get a close-up so I can move the camera
around makes you feel powerful I think
I'm gonna get a flamethrower like people
taking your parking spot like you like a
man I think I think that was my spot now
I think now I was gonna park there you
saw me did you pull them I think you
should come okay you okay expander Dan
stay there yeah all right this I'm
definitely eating a flamethrower
oh yeah you see the share aggression
yeah because it adds to the fire that's
the one thing when you learn yeah as an
actor right you know there's physical
phenomena but you got to know that your
your inner life
yeah X the phenomenon I mean that on its
own Allison we've all seen that we've
seen it I've seen that I've never seen
that with that yes exactly exactly
it's almost like it was but further yes
yes yes it was like like it was mind
over matter with the flames like
fantastic though look good there it's
harder to see outside but you can see
where I'm watching this on oh that's
good gesture that's very cool
I love that see this is what I wanted to
do this with you man
[Laughter]
so the the the current you present a you
survived you annihilated young you young
me melted right off yes
and so I think you're finished ready to
take on humanoids humanoid rockets
yes I'm read about a car Oh
because let me list off some stuff we
what could you do we've got we've got to
tell Karen Oh a potato cannon is perfect
we've got cousin Gemma sledgehammer so
yeah the potato cannon is interesting
cuz you got a little bit of like
mischief night that's involved with yeah
you know it's a little you know
Halloween vibes but yeah like that the
potato cannon is fantastic because then
you get glass dense and potato yeah the
only thing I've been told is that we
can't wreck the tires or the engine I
think everybody else is good to go sure
okay no tires no engine so why don't we
just why don't we just potato kind of
straight through here
Oh will he go through I don't know let's
see what happens how fast can a potato
yes what I want to know we'll learn that
today yes we will certainly see well
this shows
that's about learning stuff that most
people don't care about okay okay
there's no I've just there's no sight
there's a sight yeah you can't really
tell yeah it's like hipfiring potato
yeah I'm gonna get over the shoulder so
hopefully you'll actually see the
projectile make it over there and go
straight through hopefully yeah that's
what we're gonna hope for ever fired one
of these well no burr no idea how loud
is gonna no idea how loud it's gonna be
meaning idea potatoes coming back at me
no idea if this is the last time I'll
ever do it the last time you ever fire a
potato cannon
ready when you are you ready here we go
you know what I think it needs my inner
it needs my like you want screen I
wasn't yeah yeah I need my innard like
okay I got it I was I'll support it you
younger you got not you all do you be
dead too all right so listen I was 80
like let's try 201 kid great guys I
think that's the idea yeah so just gotta
get the aim
now to be fair that is crack that is
crack it is definitely cracked yeah what
do you guys think one more let's just
let's do one more we got it you know we
got to get a good one again cuz that was
there I think that was the right idea
that we just got right there and you can
come line me up on that come into line
you up yeah and then a little bit to the
right that looks good
alright here we go ready three two one
all right car wins it's amazing how much
subtle movement I know I feel like we
net you nailed the aim that time yeah
the the angle of deflection probably
kill some of the power yeah I said I
think it looked good though I think I'm
gonna let you do this yeah I'll do the
camera so yeah I'm gonna run the camera
on this oh I don't know I see I'm
usually the camera man I get it I get
all nervous I'm probably gonna witness
no no it's gonna be beautiful
okay so now that you're a slimmer guy
obviously you have to know how to use
the slimmer yes so uh huh so what do you
want it to yeah after I've hit it yeah
after we see the window break you just
pop the red behind the red button after
the window breaks of the rib it records
for five seconds so as long as you hit
it within five seconds of me hearing a
window yeah sure so I don't want to wait
at all right so you know I understand I
just hit it immediately pretty much yes
yes absolutely
also it's in a constant so the important
thing is the line you gotta get a guy Oh
a guy you old potato duck in okay yeah
so as soon as you hit it I will push the
red button
good deal all right guys old on don't
you don't rush don't rush you gotta get
your motivation right and everything and
you know
it's this is not just breaking a window
man you know there's so much more it's
so much more usually when I break
windows there's way less people watching
right all right so wait you're out of
frame a little bit that way yeah I'm
just gonna come in like this you know
coming now yeah that's better that's
right so now yeah you're in you're
you're slightly out of the frame a
little bit there you go that's perfect
if you right yep like that perfect okay
are you ready
and I'm gonna hit the button right after
you hit it all right are you ready uh
yeah just like you got use your ass
muscles cuz ass muscles are the best
with sledgehammers the glutes the glutes
yes tighten your glutes in yes yes
pelvic forward glute thrust okay you
ready
glutes this car who made this car
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah no no no that's why they do it yeah
as Gavin takes his second approach how's
my motivation on that one yeah no it was
good you like gluts was the right thing
to scream yeah I didn't I don't think
you meant it you didn't like really you
were saying gluts yeah but you weren't
like I wasn't feeling you weren't like
living in your glutes
[Laughter]
you gotta imagine your whole like in
your glutes I grew up in my glitter who
grew up in your glutes right on the
button Will Smith yeah sure super glutes
yeah there you go yeah super glues I
said let me tell you something I felt
your glutes oh it felt like in that
moment my glutes yeah yes it needed to
be super glutes cuz you say blue super
glutes is my god I see the face I like a
like a professor
and then this is the best part right you
know when something happens it's loud
and yeah exactly
it looks good looks good that's
fantastic yeah that's gonna look real
real well well yeah you come in as a as
a slow-mo guy today yeah that you've
done the slow-mo and then you filmed the
slimmer I've been wanting to do this for
so long it's an absolute pleasure it was
all the fun that I had hoped a new
knowledge of glutes was born and the
next level of Goodman next level of
lutes that was the thing because I was
you know I was thinking small and you
went to super glues right so it's a
whole other yeah when you go super
there's always room to go thank you
thank you thank you
check out Gemini man oh and subscribe to
the slow mo guys
[Laughter]